Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 39, Rust. Take it away, Patrick. Email. It's such an integral portion of our lives.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 39 期，Rust。Patrick，开始吧。电子邮件。它是我们生活中不可或缺的一部分。
It is. But what is it? Where does it come from? What does it taste like? What does it taste like? It's delicious. Jason and I were talking about how email has become increasingly a portion of our business lives. Well, I guess personal lives as well.
确实。但它是什么？它从哪里来？它尝起来是什么味道？它尝起来是什么味道？它很美味。Jason 和我一直在讨论电子邮件是如何越来越多地成为我们商业生活的一部分。好吧，我想个人生活也是如此。
But that a large portion of our day is spent using email. And we were talking about our experiences with Google's new inbox and trying to change how email is done and sharing our opinions about email for me i find that i have a horrible organizational scheme for email and i have tried all sorts of like inbox zero whatever approaches and it turns out i just end up using my email as some sort of weird to do and like i like seeing things whether they're unread read out in labeled like all these are various levels of to do for me um but inbox is nice i like it i like that i can zero inbox kind of person i don't argue that way like i can't if i have an unread email it just like makes me tick a little bit no no i have lots of unread emails in fact my lead came by one day and saw my inbox and was like you have how many unread emails so
但我们一天中很大一部分时间都花在处理电子邮件上。我们一直在讨论使用谷歌新版 Inbox 的体验，试图改变处理电子邮件的方式，并分享我们对电子邮件的看法。对我来说，我发现我的电子邮件组织方案非常糟糕，我尝试过各种“收件箱归零”之类的方法，结果我最终还是把电子邮件当作某种奇怪的待办事项列表来用。我喜欢看到各种东西，无论是未读、已读、还是贴了标签，对我来说这些都是不同层级的待办事项。嗯，但 Inbox 很不错，我喜欢它，我喜欢那种“收件箱归零”的人。我不会那样争论，如果我有一封未读邮件，它只会让我有点心烦。不不，我有很多未读邮件，事实上，我的主管有一天走过来看到我的收件箱，说：“你有多少封未读邮件？”
we're talking like i was like no no it's okay it's okay yeah yeah no not hundreds of thousands no no like hundreds oh hundreds okay i'm not that bad anymore yeah like i have it a little bit better now basically if it gets past a month i just i just archive it all like oh nice um but but yeah i use it as like a to do like i read a message and then i mark it back as unread if it's like i need to take action yeah right uh and yeah i know it doesn't work and now inbox the google one i use it for my personal and i really like it and i don't quite get to inbox zero like i still leave stuff in my inbox um although i have gotten to inbox zero with it because you can sweep away like large portions of messages which i like yeah yeah i like the whatever they call i call it the boomerang feature because that was the name
我们说的是……我当时说：“不不，没关系，没关系。”是的，是的，不是成千上万封，不不，就是几百封。哦，几百封，好吧，我现在没那么糟糕了。是的，我现在好多了。基本上，如果超过一个月，我就把它们全部归档。哦，不错。嗯，但我确实把它当作待办事项来用。我读了一封邮件，如果需要采取行动，我就把它标记为未读。是的，没错。我知道这行不通，现在谷歌的 Inbox，我把它用于个人用途，我真的很喜欢它。我并没有完全做到“收件箱归零”，我仍然会在收件箱里留一些东西。虽然我确实用它实现过“收件箱归零”，因为你可以像扫地一样清理掉大部分邮件，我喜欢这样。是的，我喜欢他们称之为……我称之为“回旋镖”功能，因为那是……
of a startup trying to do the same thing where you like say give me this email new again in a day or in 12 hours oh yeah yeah yeah when i get to work i love that feature i actually should use that i haven't used it but i think it'd be really useful. I just haven't incorporated it in my flow. But I use a lot of the, like, filters so that, like, I have a bunch of different categories and most of the email gets routed correctly. And that way things like... I have filters as well, but I find that if it's filtered out of my inbox, that just means
一家试图做同样事情的初创公司的名字，你可以说“让这封邮件在一天或 12 小时后再次提醒我”。哦，是的，是的，当我开始工作时，我喜欢这个功能。我其实应该用它，我还没用过，但我认为它会非常有用。我只是还没把它整合到我的工作流程中。但我用了很多过滤器，所以我有一堆不同的类别，大部分邮件都能被正确路由。这样一来……我也有过滤器，但我发现如果它被过滤出了我的收件箱，那就意味着
it does not get read. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, it's true. Who am I kidding? People fuss at me like, you didn't see this email mess? I'm like, no. It's in a busy stream. I don't check.
它不会被阅读。是的，差不多。是的，这是真的。我在骗谁呢？人们会对我大惊小怪，说：“你没看到这封邮件吗？”我说：“没有，它在繁忙的流中，我没检查。”
Yeah, I have this one mailing list at work, and they put automated emails, like test results, but then it's also used for real communication communication. And that's the worst. Cause basically that's just, that's just a black hole for me. Like people are like, Hey, did you get my email? I said, did you post it to this group? And they go, yeah. I'm like, Nope, that's not going to happen. And then they're always like, there's ways around it. Like, Oh, well, this, the test emails always come from the same thing. Or always having a suffix at the end or something and it's like now my rules just have to get really yeah this is silly yeah
是的，我在工作中有一个邮件列表，他们会发送自动邮件，比如测试结果，但它也被用于真正的沟通。那是这辈子最糟糕的。因为基本上那对我来说就是一个黑洞。就像人们问：“嘿，你收到我的邮件了吗？”我说：“你发到这个群组了吗？”他们说：“是的。”我说：“不，那是不可能的。”然后他们总是说：“有办法解决的。”比如：“哦，好吧，这些测试邮件总是来自同一个地址，或者结尾总是有个后缀什么的。”现在我的规则必须变得非常……是的，这太愚蠢了。
um but actually you know there was that time where they were trying to do google wave as like a replacement for email but that um didn't really take off i really really think email is one of the last few things that needs a refresh. We completely refreshed the way video works. You go from your camcorder to YouTube. So many things
嗯，但实际上，你知道有段时间他们试图用 Google Wave 来取代电子邮件，但那并没有真正流行起来。我真的认为电子邮件是最后几个需要更新的东西之一。我们彻底更新了视频的工作方式。你从摄像机转到了 YouTube。现在有太多的东西
now are just completely fundamentally different than they were before. But email is basically the same thing. I i mean there's smart filters and there's some ways to manage it but the medium itself hasn't really changed i mean in fact just the way email uses those greater than signs to like tell you that it's a reply email like like none of that that whole hacky protocol has stayed the same all those years well even the fact that most of the email
与以前完全不同了。但电子邮件基本上还是老样子。我的意思是，有智能过滤器，也有一些管理方法，但媒介本身并没有真正改变。事实上，电子邮件使用那些大于号来告诉你这是一封回复邮件，这种黑客式的协议多年来一直保持不变。好吧，甚至大多数电子邮件
has moved to conversations like threads right kind of like more like forum posts or whatever it would almost be better if like when you sent an email instead you were just creating like a wiki entry somewhere and like this is kind of the wave thing a little like and everyone can kind of edit it but not just like an open form edit, but just more like a, you know, instant message thread, but it's indexed like an email, right? Like somewhere, the problem is some people use email as documentation, like a true wiki or, you know, online document or even emailing word docs. Other people use it as ephemeral, like text messaging. So it needs to support both cases. And it has to be backwards compatible because you're not gonna
都已经转向了对话，也就是线程，对吧？有点像论坛帖子之类的。如果当你发送一封电子邮件时，你实际上是在某个地方创建了一个维基条目，那会更好。这有点像 Wave 的东西，每个人都可以编辑它，但不是那种开放式的表单编辑，而更像是一个即时通讯线程，但它像电子邮件一样被索引，对吧？问题是有些人把电子邮件当作文档，就像真正的维基或在线文档，甚至通过电子邮件发送 Word 文档。而另一些人则把它当作短暂的东西，就像短信一样。所以它需要支持这两种情况。而且它必须向后兼容，因为你不可能
get everyone off email in a day right that's right that's i think the big problem with wave was that you know the the first thing wave should have done is like allow it should have taken your entire inbox and converted it to wave you know um yeah it's hard though because even like at work we use google docs a lot and we had a vendor we were working with and we sent him a link to the google doc which he could access just fine but he's like oh i didn't like working in the google doc so i copied all your google doc into a microsoft word doc so like let's use this to collaborate and it was like what this is like fine you may not like google docs but like emailing a version word doc around is the worst microsoft go to like parallel editing i thought microsoft had a cloud-based thing now but people i don't as far as i know people still just like
一天之内让所有人都放弃电子邮件，对吧？没错，我认为 Wave 的大问题在于，Wave 首先应该做的是允许它获取你的整个收件箱并将其转换为 Wave。嗯，这很难，因为即使在工作中，我们也经常使用 Google Docs，我们有一个正在合作的供应商，我们发给他一个 Google Doc 的链接，他可以正常访问，但他却说：“哦，我不喜欢在 Google Doc 里工作，所以我把你们的 Google Doc 全部复制到了 Microsoft Word 文档里，让我们用这个来协作。”当时我就想：“什么？这没问题，你可能不喜欢 Google Docs，但到处通过电子邮件发送 Word 文档版本是最糟糕的。”微软去搞并行编辑吧。我以为微软现在有云端功能了，但据我所知，人们仍然只是
take a dot doc and email it and then you're supposed to make edits or suggestions and email it back that's so bad that's so bad so so there's another thing actually now i think about it is sending a file like that still hasn't been solved like why is that still so hard you know like if i have the other day i had like a two gigabyte file and i wanted it it was a bunch of pictures. I wanted to send it to my parents and I realized it's just no, there's just no way for me to do this. I mean like, you know, so there's such that my parents could receive the file without being like wizards or anything,
拿一个 .doc 文件并通过电子邮件发送，然后你得进行编辑或提出建议，再通过电子邮件发回去。这太糟糕了，太糟糕了。所以，还有一件事，现在我想起来了，发送文件仍然没有解决。为什么这仍然这么难？你知道，如果我有……前几天我有一个 2GB 的文件，是一堆照片。我想发给我的父母，但我意识到根本没有办法做到这一点。我的意思是，你知道，没有办法让我的父母在不是电脑高手的情况下收到这个文件，
you know? Well, the problem is like, where do you store it? Like your parents want a version of that file or the option to keep the file, but so you can't just host it from you because they also want to copy. But two gigabytes is a lot for them not to agree to accept.
你知道吗？嗯，问题是，你把它存在哪里？你的父母想要那个文件的版本或保留文件的选项，所以你不能只从你那里托管它，因为他们也想要一份副本。但 2GB 对他们来说太大了，他们可能不会同意接收。
Right. Yeah. And there's no like third party like Dropbox or someone could like host a file and you could email the Dropbox link. But then you trust that they copied it down before you remove it or whatever. Yeah, I mean the best thing I've ever used for this, and by best, I mean, like, most idiot-proof, was AOL Instant Messenger, where I could literally just drop a file into AIM, and it would just get sent to that person,
没错。是的。而且没有像 Dropbox 这样的第三方可以托管文件，然后你可以通过电子邮件发送 Dropbox 链接。但你得相信他们在你删除它之前已经下载了它，或者其他什么。是的，我用过的最好的工具，我指的“最好”是指最傻瓜式的，是 AOL Instant Messenger，我可以字面意义上地把文件拖进 AIM，它就会直接发送给那个人，
and they would have it. But that was only if the person was there. Yeah, I mean, that's fine. Oh, yeah. But anyways. But for that, you can use Dropbox, dropbox right like you can put it in dropbox send the link and then when they download it just delete it yeah if i had two gigs free on my dropbox but uh i don't have that that's the problem anyway you mean you're not paying them
他们就会收到。但那只有在对方在线时才行。是的，我的意思是，那没关系。哦，是的。但无论如何。但对于那个，你可以使用 Dropbox，对吧？你可以把它放在 Dropbox 里，发送链接，然后当他们下载后就删掉它。是的，如果我的 Dropbox 有 2GB 的免费空间的话，但我没有，这就是问题所在。总之，你的意思是你不付钱给他们？
i know i'm i want to freeload but I also want everything they have. That's called buying. Yeah. So we have some user feedback. Yeah, we have some awesome user feedback. Thanks. This is collected from email and from the G Plus and Facebook pages and community, or community and page, respectively. But Simon, or Simmon, you, he he told us he gave us a pretty cool link there's this tool called ispc and it lets you take c code and turn it into simd
我知道，我想白嫖，但我也想要他们拥有的一切。那叫购买。是的。所以我们有一些用户反馈。是的，我们有一些很棒的用户反馈。谢谢。这些是从电子邮件、G Plus 和 Facebook 页面以及社区收集的。但是 Simon，或者 Simmon，他告诉我们，他给了我们一个很酷的链接，有一个叫 ispc 的工具，它让你获取 C 代码并将其转换为 SIMD
um so i haven't tried it or anything but uh it looks cool it's on github so i'm assuming it's open source. And yeah, I mean, it looks pretty awesome. I wonder how it works. Let me see. Overview. So SIMD was, for those of you not following along, was last episode, episode 38. That's right. So yeah, apparently it's an extension to the compiler so and it uses LLVM so you compile a bunch of your code to LLVM you compile this to LLVM and then
嗯，我还没试过，但它看起来很酷，它在 GitHub 上，所以我假设它是开源的。是的，我的意思是，它看起来非常棒。我想知道它是怎么工作的。让我看看。概述。所以 SIMD，对于那些没跟上的人来说，是上一期，第 38 期。没错。所以，是的，显然它是编译器的扩展，它使用 LLVM，所以你把一堆代码编译成 LLVM，你把这个编译成 LLVM，然后
now everything's LLVM so it just kind of works cool I'll have to check that out it's pretty awesome so not exactly SIMD but we've talked about CUDA before and I had someone tell me today because we were talking actually about simd and they brought up cuda that if you are a cuda programmer apparently you can make mad money really that's what they told me i don't know if that's true but they said that the demand for gpu programmers is so crazy and the supply so bad that if you can do that that you can make as they said mad money are you doing gpu right now oh so you're so there's the potential i mean we both so so just some background patrick and i did
现在一切都是 LLVM，所以它就那样工作了。酷，我得去看看。它非常棒。所以不完全是 SIMD，但我们之前谈过 CUDA，今天有人告诉我，因为我们实际上在谈论 SIMD，他们提到了 CUDA，如果你是一个 CUDA 程序员，显然你可以赚大钱。真的吗？他们就是这么告诉我的，我不知道这是不是真的，但他们说 GPU 程序员的需求太疯狂了，而供应又太差，所以如果你能做到这一点，你就能赚到他们所说的“大钱”。你现在在做 GPU 编程吗？哦，所以你有潜力。我的意思是，我们俩……所以，背景是 Patrick 和我做过
gpu programming uh several years ago so yeah so that's what i was thinking is like man apparently i'm not apparently there's mad money to be made. But he also wasn't doing it. So apparently, the money must not be that bad. You know, that's like an investor who tells you, you know, buy this stock, buy this stock. But then, you know, they don't have any of it or they're shorting it or something. So cool. So Nicholas Baring. And oh, by the way, all these people's names were public. So, but if I am saying your name and you're super offended, let me know, because I won't do it anymore.
GPU 编程……几年前。所以，是的，这就是我所想的，天哪，显然有大钱可赚。但他也没在做。所以显然，钱一定没那么好赚。你知道，这就像一个投资者告诉你，买这只股票，买这只股票。但后来，你知道，他们自己根本没有持有，或者他们在做空它之类的。所以很酷。Nicholas Baring。哦，顺便说一下，所有这些人的名字都是公开的。所以，如果我说了你的名字而你感到非常冒犯，请告诉我，因为我以后不会再这样做了。
But as far as I know, it's okay. Nicholas Baring said, I made a comment in an earlier episode about how it's better to throw exceptions. He found some article where they said basically never throw exceptions um you know like the program should always survive and if there's some crazy case you know you should handle it and maybe log an error or something but don't like crash the program um but i think it's interesting i mean it's obviously a different perspective um i think a lot of it depends on the specific program. So, I mean, for example, if you're doing like a front end web server, then you don't want, you know, the person clicks the follow button and, you know, it just crashes.
但据我所知，没关系。Nicholas Baring 说，我在之前的一期节目中评论过抛出异常更好。他发现了一篇文章，里面基本上说永远不要抛出异常。嗯，你知道，程序应该始终存活，如果有一些疯狂的情况，你应该处理它，也许记录一个错误什么的，但不要让程序崩溃。但我认为这很有趣，我的意思是，这显然是一个不同的视角。我认为很大程度上取决于具体的程序。所以，我的意思是，例如，如果你在做一个前端 Web 服务器，那么你肯定不希望用户点击“关注”按钮，然后它就崩溃了。
So there's definitely things where, and I would maybe even go so far as to say the majority of things you have to sort of fail gracefully. It just so happens that most of the things I work on you can kind of fail loudly and if the whole binary dies nothing's impacted immediately. But I think he did bring a valid point and the article is actually quite interesting. So definitely check it out.
所以肯定有些事情，我甚至会说大多数事情，你必须优雅地失败。碰巧我工作的大多数事情都可以大声地失败，如果整个二进制文件死掉，也不会立即产生影响。但我认为他确实提出了一个有效的观点，那篇文章实际上非常有趣。所以一定要去看看。
It's a different perspective on it. It probably depends on the language too, so yeah that's true like some languages are so like even for instance like in java right like in java you a lot of those libraries and stuff you call will throw exceptions and then you're kind of forced to deal with it so if you're already dealing with it throwing your own in my opinion i'm going to get flack for it probably but is that like throwing your own isn't that big a deal since code's already having to be set up to handle it. Versus like in C++, that's not normally the default, throwing exceptions. Right. So if you start doing it, who knows if other people who try to use your code will be set up to handle exceptions or not.
这是一个不同的视角。这可能也取决于语言，所以是的，这是真的。比如在 Java 中，你调用的很多库和东西都会抛出异常，然后你被迫去处理它。所以如果你已经在处理它了，抛出你自己的异常，在我看来——我可能会因此受到抨击——抛出你自己的异常并不是什么大不了的事，因为代码已经设置好去处理它了。相比之下，在 C++ 中，抛出异常通常不是默认设置。没错。所以如果你开始这样做，谁知道其他人尝试使用你的代码时是否准备好处理异常。
Yeah, and it depends on the framework too. Like if you're doing, say, a website, you typically have like a thread pool. And if one of the threads crashes, it just spins up another one. And so all that really happens is that specific web request kind of fails, but you move on. But if you're doing something else, like some kind of device app, device side programming or something, and throwing an exception that isn't caught means killing the entire binary and now nobody can do anything, then obviously you have to
是的，这也取决于框架。比如如果你在做一个网站，你通常有一个线程池。如果其中一个线程崩溃了，它只是启动另一个。所以真正发生的一切只是那个特定的 Web 请求失败了，但你继续前进。但如果你在做其他事情，比如某种设备应用、设备端编程之类的，抛出一个未被捕获的异常意味着杀死整个二进制文件，现在没人能做任何事情，那么显然你必须
not throw any exceptions there. Finally, you have Bence Magyar. Hopefully I got your name right. Bence Magyar. He linked to this pretty cool Python library called Bokeh
在那里不抛出任何异常。最后，你有 Bence Magyar。希望我没念错你的名字。Bence Magyar。他链接到了一个很酷的 Python 库，叫 Bokeh
and it's a visualization library for the browser written in Python. So I definitely want to check this out. Personally I think this would be pretty cool. I see a lot of value in this. I've been doing a lot of Python lately and doing a lot of visualization so I'll definitely have to take
它是一个用 Python 编写的浏览器可视化库。所以我一定要去看看。个人认为这会很酷。我看到了很多价值。我最近一直在做很多 Python，也做了很多可视化，所以我一定要去
a look at this and you guys guys should too it looks pretty cool that doesn't look great all right time for the news first article is mine uh of virginia oh i guess a university of virginia i don't know but there's a link in the show notes but there was a very good pdf that i found on how GPUs work. It looks like it was part of a magazine or something, but I didn't see it when I skimmed it, what magazine it must have been a part of. It says computer.
看看这个，你们也应该看看，它看起来很酷。看起来不错。好了，新闻时间到了。第一篇文章是我的，呃，弗吉尼亚大学，我不知道，但节目笔记里有一个链接，我发现了一份关于 GPU 如何工作的非常好的 PDF。看起来它像是杂志的一部分，但我浏览时没看到它属于哪本杂志。它写着“计算机”。
Is there a magazine called Computer? I don't know about that magazine. Yeah, I haven't heard about it. Anyways, but it's how GPU works, written by someone from the University of Virginia and someone from nvidia and it talks a little bit like we talk about and so even representing three-dimensional space use four-dimensional matrices and they give a little bit of explanation about why that is
有一本叫《计算机》的杂志吗？我不知道那本杂志。是的，我没听说过。总之，它是关于 GPU 如何工作的，由弗吉尼亚大学和 NVIDIA 的人编写，它谈到了一些我们谈论过的内容，甚至表示三维空间使用四维矩阵，他们对为什么会这样给出了一点解释
about some of the things that having a gpu allows you to do that you know weren't really feasible before about shaders about general gpu just kind of like a cursor overview it's looks like about five pages long so not that long but but a good thing we talked about we've talked about gpus a number of times and this is a good uh overview of what it is and the context behind it yeah i'll have to check this out um actually you know the gpus uh i have a friend from nvidia who is telling me that they're doing a lot more machine learning gpu activity um so i think nvidia specifically is building a bunch of machine learning libraries and stuff like that for the gpu and making that available to everybody and so uh that's pretty it. I mean, I think a lot of processors are now coming with GPUs,
关于 GPU 允许你做的一些以前并不真正可行的事情，关于着色器，关于通用 GPU，只是一个大概的概述。看起来大约有五页长，所以没那么长，但这是一个很好的东西。我们谈论过 GPU 好几次了，这是一个很好的概述，说明了它是什么以及背后的背景。是的，我得去看看。嗯，实际上，你知道 GPU，我有一个来自 NVIDIA 的朋友告诉我，他们正在做更多的机器学习 GPU 活动，所以我认为 NVIDIA 特别是在为 GPU 构建一堆机器学习库之类的东西，并让所有人都能使用它，所以这很不错。我的意思是，我认为很多处理器现在都带有 GPU，
either on the die or a lot of devices have GPUs in them and stuff like that. So we might have to revive our GPU skills. Skills with a Z. Make mad money. Yeah, that's right, to make mad money. Mad monies, also with a Z. Oh. So, this article is pretty cool.
要么在芯片上，要么很多设备里都有 GPU 之类的。所以我们可能得重拾我们的 GPU 技能。技能（Skills）用 Z 结尾。赚大钱。是的，没错，赚大钱。大钱（Mad monies），也用 Z 结尾。哦。所以，这篇文章很酷。
It's Mixpanel's pitch deck. Actually, it's funny. The article originally was open sourcing our pitch deck, and they got blasted on Hacker News for using the term open source when it wasn't source code i didn't realize this was a big deal but it's currently like a big social faux pas at least on hacker news to to use the term open source for something that isn't sourced so
这是 Mixpanel 的演示文稿（Pitch Deck）。实际上，这很有趣。这篇文章最初是“开源我们的演示文稿”，结果他们在 Hacker News 上因为使用“开源”这个词而遭到抨击，因为那不是源代码。我没意识到这是一个大问题，但目前这在 Hacker News 上是一个很大的社交禁忌，不能对非源代码的东西使用“开源”这个词。
anyway so they changed it to here's our pitch deck or something but it's pretty cool it literally is their pitch that they use to secure their like uh vc funding they got something like 70 million or something in series series b or series c and it's about how they did that uh i mean so it's the deck but it's also if you read the Hacker News comments, they also, the Mixpanel founders are there answering questions and adding commentary. And it's actually a really good read, so definitely check it out. It's pretty cool. There's a lot of things I didn't know because I'm not really in that area.
总之，他们把它改成了“这是我们的演示文稿”之类的，但它很酷，这确实是他们用来获得 B 轮或 C 轮融资的演示文稿，他们获得了大约 7000 万美元左右的资金，这是关于他们如何做到这一点的。我的意思是，这是演示文稿，但如果你阅读 Hacker News 的评论，Mixpanel 的创始人们也在那里回答问题并添加评论。这实际上是一篇很好的读物，所以一定要去看看。它很酷。有很多我不知道的事情，因为我并不真正处于那个领域。
So, for example, there's a term called KPI. That's key performance. I forgot what the I is. Do you know what the I is? Let me look it up. But it's like KPI and it was about key performance indicator. And basically it's a fancy way of saying how they're going to measure success. And they also had like, you know, their graph showing their growth and stuff like that.
所以，例如，有一个术语叫 KPI。那是关键绩效（Key Performance）。我忘了 I 是什么了。你知道 I 是什么吗？让我查一下。但它就像 KPI，是关键绩效指标（Key Performance Indicator）。基本上，这是一种花哨的说法，用来表示他们将如何衡量成功。他们还有，你知道，显示他们增长的图表之类的。
So I thought the whole thing was pretty cool. They talk about some of the things that we've talked about on the show, like have a vision and the vision is really important, have, like, a good mission statement, all that stuff. But it's cool to see, like, a living example. Oh, they have a whole thing in here for their competition yeah they had that little that uh was like an x chart or t chart or however you say that but it's the other competition they had to break it down into free paid and then
所以我认为整个事情很酷。他们谈论了一些我们在节目中谈论过的事情，比如拥有愿景，愿景非常重要，拥有一个好的使命宣言，所有这些东西。但看到一个活生生的例子很酷。哦，他们在这里有一整套关于竞争的内容。是的，他们有那个小图表，或者 T 型图，或者无论你怎么称呼它，但这是他们必须分解的另一种竞争，分为免费、付费，然后
i forgot what the other axis was yeah i always find that funny when talk to people who have an idea for something or like you ever watch like that shark tank show on the tv and then like people like oh i have no competition there is it's like well yeah you're probably doing something wrong seems really unlikely you have no competition it's like tesla tesla saying like who else makes electric sports cars well no one we have no competition it's like well your competition is every other kind of normal car. Yeah, I mean, the other thing, too, is like, even if... Now, I don't know that Tesla actually says that. That was just a hypothetical. Even if you literally have something completely brand new,
我忘了另一个轴是什么了。是的，当我和那些对某事有想法的人交谈时，我总是觉得这很有趣，或者就像你看电视上的《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）节目，然后人们说：“哦，我没有竞争对手。”这就像，好吧，是的，你可能做错了什么。看起来你没有竞争对手真的不太可能。这就像特斯拉说：“还有谁制造电动跑车？嗯，没有，我们没有竞争对手。”这就像，好吧，你的竞争对手是所有其他种类的普通汽车。是的，我的意思是，另一件事是，即使……现在，我不知道特斯拉是否真的这么说。那只是一个假设。即使你真的有完全全新的东西，
your competition are the audience of people who can clone you over the next five years, right? I mean, you always have somebody you know who can who can duplicate what you're doing given enough time and that's so yeah you should always have competition um at any rate the next article is goodbye dr dobbs who fun fact dr dobbs is not a real person it's a it's an amalgamation of two people's names i forgot what they were now i guess i should have had it ready but i looked it up earlier uh um so it's two people together founded the magazine dr dobbs and i 38 years ago apparently and they have decided the current editor and staff or whatever and the company that owned them have decided to stop publishing dr dobbs um so most people have probably at least come across dr dobbs at one time
你的竞争对手是那些在未来五年内可以克隆你的人群，对吧？我的意思是，你总是有某个人，你知道，可以在有足够时间的情况下复制你正在做的事情。所以，是的，你应该总是有竞争对手。无论如何，下一篇文章是“再见，Dr. Dobbs”。有趣的事实是，Dr. Dobbs 不是一个真实的人，它是两个人的名字的合并。我现在忘了他们是谁了，我想我应该准备好的，但我之前查过。嗯，所以是两个人一起创立了《Dr. Dobbs》杂志，38 年前。显然，现任编辑和员工，或者无论什么，以及拥有他们的公司，已经决定停止出版《Dr. Dobbs》。所以大多数人可能至少接触过《Dr. Dobbs》一次
or another um they have a huge corpus of like programming related content so they get a lot of search hits when you search various programming topics um and i don't know that i've ever subscribed to the magazine in college i think they had it around so i think i've read dr dobbs in print before okay um that's where they put it on a dead dead tree paper and like um i don't know the magazines are that common anymore i guess they are and uh and so they're they're finally stopping and the guy was making a point he's like it's kind of the the person writing the article it's kind of the, the person writing the article, it's kind of interesting because their website currently has a more page
或者其他。嗯，他们有海量的编程相关内容，所以当你搜索各种编程主题时，他们会获得很多搜索点击。我不知道我是否曾经订阅过这本杂志。在大学里，我想他们周围有这本杂志，所以我认为我以前读过纸质版的《Dr. Dobbs》。好的，那是他们把它放在死树纸上的时候。嗯，我不知道杂志现在是否那么普遍了，我想是的。所以他们终于要停刊了。那个人提出了一个观点，他说这有点……写这篇文章的人，这有点有趣，因为他们的网站目前有比以往任何时候都多的页面
views than ever has had before. And it's been growing for over the last three years. That's still, you know, a pretty significant clip. Um, but that, you know how much they're making,
浏览量。而且在过去三年里一直在增长。这仍然是一个相当显著的增长速度。嗯，但是，你知道他们赚了多少钱，
it's going down because basically they relied on, um, pay-per-view ad and the pay-per-view ad industry is just, like, drying up. Yeah, right. Because it turns out no one clicks on those ads. No one, like, is not helping anybody by seeing them. People block them from their vision. And so they're actually, their ability to make money has suffered.
它正在下降，因为基本上他们依赖于按次付费广告，而按次付费广告行业正在枯竭。是的，没错。因为事实证明没人点击那些广告。没人，就像，看到它们对任何人都没有帮助。人们把它们从视野中屏蔽了。所以他们赚钱的能力实际上受到了损害。
Yeah, I mean, it's like they didn't really keep up with the times, you know? I mean, they, like, the website itself looks very dated, and the content is up to date. But, yeah, it just feels like their business hasn't really adapted. I wonder how, like, how do, like, TechCrunch and these other sites make money? That's through pay-per-view ads, right? Is it just so there's, like, display ads or whatever, but it also, like, click ads, maybe click ads. Oh, I see. Also, I don't think, like, when these people say they have a lot of views, I don't think the views approach something like, you know, TechCrunch.
是的，我的意思是，就像他们没有真正跟上时代一样，你知道吗？我的意思是，网站本身看起来非常过时，内容是最新的。但是，是的，感觉他们的业务并没有真正适应。我想知道 TechCrunch 和其他网站是怎么赚钱的？是通过按次付费广告，对吧？是只有展示广告之类的，还是点击广告，也许是点击广告。哦，我明白了。另外，我不认为当这些人说他们有很多浏览量时，浏览量会接近 TechCrunch 之类的。
TechCrunch probably has, like, an order or two of magnitude more page views. Yeah, right. That makes sense. So, I mean, I don't know um yeah yeah i mean that i mean and then also i think people like tech crunch and stuff they now like they run conferences and stuff too right and like people pay to go there be a vendor there yeah that's what it is that's actually the right answer i mean at that they uh yeah you're right all of these people even like node.js and stuff they have the node.js conference and it's like a thousand dollars to go you know um yeah these people didn't really
TechCrunch 的页面浏览量可能比他们多一两个数量级。是的，没错。这说得通。所以，我的意思是，我不知道。嗯，是的，我的意思是，还有，我认为像 TechCrunch 之类的人，他们现在也举办会议之类的，对吧？人们付钱去那里，成为那里的供应商。是的，就是这样，这才是正确答案。我的意思是，他们……是的，你是对的，所有这些人，甚至像 Node.js 之类的，他们有 Node.js 大会，去那里要一千美元，你知道。嗯，是的，这些人并没有真正
jump on that bandwagon among other things but uh yeah so i mean i still get like magazines but the magazines i get are typically much like lighter fare uh dr dobbs is like i guess would it be considered like a trade journal i don't know like i've never really read sat down and read computer science magazine trade journal type stuff yeah right it's either more tactical where i go to like stack overflow like how do i solve this problem yeah or like someone's blog post which i guess would be similar to this yeah another part of it is they didn't really handle the social side correctly. Like, you have to log in to comment. And so, like, nobody's going to do that. But,
赶上那股潮流，除其他事项外。但，是的，我的意思是，我仍然会收到杂志，但我收到的杂志通常是更轻松的内容。《Dr. Dobbs》就像，我想它会被认为是行业期刊吗？我不知道，我从来没有真正坐下来读过计算机科学杂志、行业期刊之类的东西。是的，没错，它要么更具战术性，我去 Stack Overflow 查“我该如何解决这个问题”，要么是某人的博客文章，我想这和这个类似。是的，另一部分是他们没有真正正确地处理社交方面。比如，你必须登录才能评论。所以，没人会那样做。但是，
anyways, I won't sit there and bash Dr. Jobs. Dr. Jobs is a great site. It has a lot of good... I really hope that they keep it on the internet archive or something so that all their historical information... No, I think he said the intention is to keep serving the webpages because they are enormously popular. they are enormously popular they just won't make new content
无论如何，我不会坐在那里抨击 Dr. Dobbs。《Dr. Dobbs》是一个很棒的网站。它有很多好的……我真的希望他们把它保留在互联网档案或其他地方，以便他们所有的历史信息……不，我想他说打算继续提供网页服务，因为它们非常受欢迎。它们非常受欢迎，只是他们不会再制作新内容了。
that's right okay um cool so uh yeah this is pretty interesting so there's a bug so you know you always see these articles like the bash one what was that called um the thing in bash i'll look it up keep going so. So there's Bash. There's the Heartbleed, which everyone knows about, the bug in SSL. Shell Shock. Shell Shock. And usually, I don't know too much about the Bash one, but I know the Heartbleed one, it's something, like, ridiculously complicated with, like, somebody can, like, look at the response times
没错。好的，嗯，酷。所以，是的，这很有趣。有一个漏洞，你知道你总是看到这些文章，比如 Bash 的那个，那叫什么来着？Bash 里的那个东西，我会查一下，继续说。所以有 Bash。有 Heartbleed，每个人都知道，SSL 中的漏洞。Shell Shock。Shell Shock。通常，我对 Bash 的那个了解不多，但我知道 Heartbleed，它有点像，极其复杂，有人可以，比如，查看响应时间
and, like, you know, fit a distribution to it and, like, do all this crazy math. And it's, like, something you'd see in csi but this this this like exploit is very very simple basically um you know the way your git repository works you have a folder called dot git and in your dot git folder you have all this all these things among of which which is this folder called hooks. And in the.git slash hooks folder, you can do hooks. So, for example, every time you commit, you can save the date to a file. I have a friend who every time he did a git commit, it took a picture using his laptop camera. And so he has a picture annotated with the commit so you can see like how for how stressed he was and he was making the commit just goofy
并且，比如，拟合一个分布，并进行所有这些疯狂的数学计算。这就像你在《CSI》中看到的那样，但这个漏洞非常非常简单。基本上，你知道你的 Git 仓库是如何工作的，你有一个叫 .git 的文件夹，在你的 .git 文件夹里，你有所有这些东西，其中之一就是这个叫 hooks 的文件夹。在 .git/hooks 文件夹里，你可以做钩子。例如，每次你提交时，你可以把日期保存到一个文件里。我有一个朋友，每次他做 git commit 时，它都会用他的笔记本电脑摄像头拍一张照片。所以他有一张带有提交注释的照片，这样你就可以看到他当时有多紧张，他在做提交时只是做些傻事。
stuff but you could also do really productive things like you know check the code make sure it's formatted and if it's not formatted like it was not auto formatted then fail the commit etc so now if somebody in their git repository has like a dot git folder and then had a hooks folder and made their own hook then that'd be pretty bad right because what could happen is you would clone the repository and you would also end up inheriting all of these hooks that could you know basically execute arbitrary code on your machine so git tries to be smart about this and they say look in your git repository you can't have a dot git folder because because you would be able to do this right but they didn't
但你也可以做非常有成效的事情，比如检查代码，确保它格式化了，如果它没有自动格式化，那么提交失败等等。所以现在，如果某人在他们的 Git 仓库里有一个 .git 文件夹，然后有一个 hooks 文件夹，并制作了他们自己的钩子，那会很糟糕，对吧？因为可能发生的是，你克隆了仓库，你最终也会继承所有这些钩子，它们可以，你知道，基本上在你的机器上执行任意代码。所以 Git 试图在这方面变得聪明，他们说，看，在你的 Git 仓库里，你不能有一个 .git 文件夹，因为因为你将能够做到这一点，对吧？但他们没有
think about case insensitive so if you have for example like a dot capital g IT folder, then it says, oh, that's fine. But on Windows, that's not fine. And on Mac, it's not fine because the Mac has the HFS case insensitive by default. So yeah, all you have to do is make a dot capital G git folder and then make a hooks folder and then, you know,
考虑到大小写不敏感。所以如果你有，例如，一个 .GIT 文件夹，那么它说，哦，那没关系。但在 Windows 上，那不行。在 Mac 上也不行，因为 Mac 默认有 HFS 大小写不敏感。所以，是的，你所要做的就是创建一个 .GIT 文件夹，然后创建一个 hooks 文件夹，然后，你知道，
RMRF someone's hard drive and anyone who clones your repository and does a commit will wipe out their own hard drive and of course you can do a lot worse than that right so um so do they actually find this happening or they just someone discovered this was a possibility and then they kind of stopped it um that's a great question you know they're never going to tell you that right um they're never gonna say like you know who uh like how they found this right um let me look yeah no well sometimes you know because sometimes like you find like the way it's found is a circulating worm or something right oh i see so i haven't i haven't heard anything about it. Maybe this is how those hackers got into Sony.
删除某人的硬盘，任何克隆你的仓库并进行提交的人都会擦除他们自己的硬盘。当然，你可以做比那更糟糕的事情，对吧？所以，他们真的发现这种情况发生了吗？还是有人发现这是一种可能性，然后他们就阻止了它？这是一个很好的问题，你知道他们永远不会告诉你，对吧？他们永远不会说，比如，你知道谁，他们是如何发现这一点的。让我看看。是的，不，有时你知道，因为有时，比如你发现，发现的方式是循环蠕虫之类的，对吧？哦，我明白了。所以我还没听说过任何关于它的消息。也许这就是那些黑客进入索尼的方式。
Oh, yeah, it's another story. But, yeah, so basically if you have Git, you should upgrade to 2.2.1. Or at least, you know, until you do that, just look at the repository you're cloning and just make sure it doesn't have a.git folder you know if you're doing this well GitHub is saying that they're blocking it like they're not allowing it anymore that's right yes
哦，是的，那是另一个故事。但是，是的，所以基本上如果你有 Git，你应该升级到 2.2.1。或者至少，你知道，在你这样做之前，只需查看你正在克隆的仓库，确保它没有 .git 文件夹。如果你正在这样做，GitHub 说他们正在阻止它，他们不再允许它了。没错，是的。
and then they scanned all their repositories and fixed it so it should be impossible to happen on GitHub that's right so on GitHub you're fine I'm assuming most of these sites are doing something similar so yeah in general it shouldn't be a big deal if you upgrade to git 2.2.1 you're guaranteed not to have this problem
然后他们扫描了他们所有的仓库并修复了它，所以它在 GitHub 上应该是不可能发生的。没错，所以在 GitHub 上你是安全的。我假设大多数这些网站都在做类似的事情。所以，是的，总的来说，如果你升级到 Git 2.2.1，这不应该是一个大问题，你保证不会有这个问题。
but yeah I thought that was kind of interesting time for tool of the show tool of the show my tool is not out yet I played it on the desktop I know I'm totally this is the worst kind of cheating but they said it would come out in 2014, so they have like, what,
但，是的，我觉得这很有趣。节目工具时间。节目工具时间。我的工具还没出来。我在桌面上玩过它。我知道我完全是作弊，这是最糟糕的作弊，但他们说它会在 2014 年出来，所以他们有，什么，
12 days to pull this off. But it's on desktop. It's coming to Android and iOS this year. It's called This War of Mine. And basically, it's The Sims, but think of it as like
12 天来完成这个。但它在桌面上。它今年会来到 Android 和 iOS。它叫《这是我的战争》（This War of Mine）。基本上，它是《模拟人生》（The Sims），但把它想象成
The Sims on hard mode. You know, like like if you've ever played the sims it's very tame right like you the only thing that's really getting in your way is aging and you can turn that off so you know you kind of go through you you learn how to cook you do things at your own pace and uh but it's fun because you're constantly getting better and you grow a family and you see the growth and the growth is addicting you know being a part of that um the thing that kills me about the sims is that it doesn't feel like a game to me it feels like a simulation kind of as the name says and i really wanted the sim like experience, but with a game where like I could lose and their enemies.
困难模式下的《模拟人生》。你知道，如果你玩过《模拟人生》，它非常温和，对吧？唯一真正阻碍你的是衰老，你可以把它关掉。所以，你知道，你经历它，你学习如何做饭，你按照自己的节奏做事。但这很有趣，因为你不断地变得更好，你组建了一个家庭，你看到了成长，这种成长让人上瘾，你知道，成为其中的一部分。关于《模拟人生》，让我抓狂的是，它对我来说感觉不像一个游戏，它感觉像一个模拟，正如名字所说。我真的很想要《模拟人生》那样的体验，但要有一个我可以输掉的游戏，而且有敌人。
And this is exactly that. So in this game, you basically are playing the Sims, but in this war torn Yugoslavia. And it's very hard to survive. Even to just grow food is extremely difficult. And the goal is to survive for, I won't spoil it, but for a certain number of days. And as things go on, you get more and more desperate because it's very hard to become sustainable.
而这正是那样。所以在这个游戏里，你基本上是在玩《模拟人生》，但在饱受战争蹂躏的南斯拉夫。生存非常困难。即使只是种植食物也极其困难。目标是生存，我不会剧透，但要生存一定天数。随着事情的发展，你变得越来越绝望，因为变得可持续非常困难。
So I'm trying to look here. I don't actually understand. Is it a multiplayer game, a single-player game? It's like The Sims, so it's single-player. I mean, you're managing multiple Sims, but it's totally the sims so it's single player i mean you're managing multiple sims but uh but it's totally single player um it's it has another thing that's pretty cool so in later versions of the sims they had this sort of uh vacation mode where you'd go on a vacation somewhere and then it becomes almost like an adventure game um this kind of took that idea so at the end of every day so after i think it's 12 hours of
所以我正试图在这里看。我其实不明白。这是一个多人游戏，还是单人游戏？它就像《模拟人生》，所以它是单人游戏。我的意思是，你在管理多个模拟市民，但它完全是《模拟人生》，所以它是单人游戏。我的意思是，你在管理多个模拟市民，但它完全是单人游戏。它还有另一件很酷的事情。所以在《模拟人生》的后期版本中，他们有这种度假模式，你去某个地方度假，然后它几乎变成了一个冒险游戏。这个游戏采用了那个想法。所以每天结束时，也就是在 12 小时之后
of in-game time uh you can scavenge and so you pick one of your sims and you send them and now the game becomes kind of like a kind of like a point and click adventure in a sense but like you gather resources you trade with people so like during the day you can uh make moonshine and then at night you can sell the moonshine to soldiers for money and then uh and then use that money to buy bread and anyways there's a whole economy thing going on but it's really cool i had a incredible amount of fun playing it i got kind of burnt out because i played i was playing like all nighters playing it was kind got kind of burnt out because I was playing like all-nighters playing it. It was kind of ridiculous.
的游戏时间，你可以去搜刮。所以你选择一个你的模拟市民，你派他们去，现在游戏变得有点像点击式冒险游戏，但你收集资源，你与人交易。所以白天你可以酿私酒，晚上你可以把私酒卖给士兵换钱，然后用那些钱买面包。总之，整个经济系统都在运行。但我玩得非常开心。我有点精疲力竭，因为我玩得通宵达旦，玩得有点精疲力竭，因为我玩得通宵达旦。这有点荒谬。
And then I beat the game, and then I was like, okay, I got to take a break. But I actually want to play it again. I'll definitely be buying it on iOS when it comes out. So, yeah, check it out. All right. My title is also, well, I guess it's only iOS, but also mobile, and it's called Vainglory. You may have seen this
然后我通关了游戏，然后我就想，好吧，我得休息一下。但我其实想再玩一次。它在 iOS 上发布时，我一定会买的。所以，是的，去看看吧。好了。我的标题也是，好吧，我猜它只有 iOS，但也属于移动端，它叫《虚荣》（Vainglory）。你可能见过这个
on advertisements on the actual television they've been running ads for it and i believe as part of the wwdc presentation uh where they talked about the new metal api for doing graphics processing on ios and this is a massive online battle arena is that right moba um which is apparently the hot thing i'd never played a moba before until i tried this one and i did really miserable at this one for a while and now i think i'm doing slightly less miserable um but it looks really beautiful like it's really amazing um like on it doesn't feel like it's a mobile game it feels like it could be a pc using a mouse and a keyboard it really feels good and high quality, and it doesn't feel weird or hard.
在电视广告上，他们一直在播放它的广告，我相信作为 WWDC 演示的一部分，他们谈到了用于 iOS 图形处理的新 Metal API，这是一个大型多人在线竞技游戏，对吧，MOBA，这显然是目前最热门的东西，在尝试这个游戏之前我从没玩过 MOBA，起初我玩得非常糟糕，但现在我想我玩得稍微没那么糟糕了，但它看起来真的很漂亮，真的很棒，它感觉不像是一个手机游戏，感觉就像是在电脑上用鼠标和键盘玩一样，感觉真的很棒，质量很高，而且不会让人觉得奇怪或困难。
I've played other games where there are supposed to be sometimes PC ports or PC quality style games, and the controls are very awkward and weird and it just doesn't work out well, and I didn't ever feel like that with this one. Yeah, I've also been playing Vainglory. Yeah, I think it's great. I actually always kind of wondered how the UI would work one yeah i've also been playing vainglory uh yeah i think it's great it's it's i actually i always
我玩过其他号称有 PC 移植版或 PC 质量风格的游戏，但操作非常笨拙和奇怪，效果并不好，我在这款游戏中从未有过这种感觉。是的，我也一直在玩《虚荣》(Vainglory)。是的，我觉得它很棒。我其实一直很好奇它的用户界面是如何运作的，是的，我也一直在玩《虚荣》，是的，我觉得它很棒，我其实一直
kind of wondered how the ui would work for a moba because you know there's times where you have to click across so you've played other mobas before though yeah i've played like desktop mobas and you know one of the things like clicking on the other side of the map to go to a strategic location the way they did that where i mean i don't know how you do it but the way i do it i use my middle finger on the mini map to like pan it around then when i have the spot i want to use my index finger to just tap anywhere on that screen yeah something sort of like yeah yeah so the way they did that was very clever um also so in most MOBAs, the enemy's health, like the little grunts, their health doesn't turn colors when you can one-shot them.
很好奇 MOBA 的用户界面是如何运作的，因为你知道，有时候你必须点击屏幕另一端，所以你以前玩过其他 MOBA 游戏吗？是的，我玩过桌面端的 MOBA，你知道其中一件事就是点击地图的另一端去往战略位置，他们实现这一点的方式，我是说，我不知道你是怎么做的，但我通常用中指在小地图上拖动平移，当我找到想要的位置时，我会用食指点击屏幕上的任何地方，是的，类似那样，是的，是的，所以他们这样做非常聪明，而且在大多数 MOBA 游戏中，敌人的生命值，比如那些小兵，当你可以一击必杀时，它们的生命值颜色不会改变。
And that actually makes a huge difference. Because with, like, Dota... Oh, I didn't know this. Wait, wait. So when they're on their last hit from you, is the only time it changes colors? So, yeah, like, the enemies, the little grunts, they have a regular health bar but when you can like when the game calculates you can last hit them the bar turns like a bright red
而这实际上产生了巨大的差异。因为在《Dota》中……哦，我不知道这一点。等等，等等。所以只有当它们处于你最后一下攻击的范围内时，颜色才会改变？所以，是的，比如敌人，那些小兵，它们有一个普通的生命条，但当游戏计算出你可以完成最后一击时，生命条会变成亮红色。
oh i didn't yeah and so that makes a gigantic difference because in dota um you have to constantly like you know because you have a desktop with a big screen the health bars are bigger and you have to sort of look at the health bar how many pixels wide it is and make a judgment call on if you can do the last hit and often you're wrong and it doesn't completely kill the enemy and so as soon as you go to mobile this becomes even more frustrating with the health bars being small right so they they just they just said look we're not going to play this game we're just going to tell you when it's a last hit and i thought that was clever um so yeah basically they got a bunch of things right uh with this game so i think it's pretty awesome and it's free to play i think most mobas are now right yeah that's right yeah totally free to play
哦，我不知道，是的，这产生了巨大的差异，因为在《Dota》中，你必须不断地，你知道，因为你有大屏幕的桌面，生命条更大，你必须观察生命条有多少像素宽，并判断你是否能完成最后一击，通常你会判断错误，没能完全杀死敌人，所以一旦你转到手机上，随着生命条变小，这变得更加令人沮丧，对吧？所以他们只是说，看，我们不会那样做，我们只是会在可以完成最后一击时告诉你，我觉得这很聪明，所以是的，基本上他们在这个游戏中做对了很多事情，所以我认为它非常棒，而且它是免费游玩的，我想现在大多数 MOBA 游戏都是这样，对吧？是的，没错，完全免费游玩。
you can that's like the and so in this one the only thing as far as i can tell that you spend money on is they have a rotation of characters and only a subset are available for free to play at any given time so if you want to guarantee your favorite character is always available you have to you know buy it with either in-game currency or currency that you converted normal dollars you converted to in-game currency or whatever but right now they don't have any other way to spend your money as far as yeah that's i think that's right so yeah the um defense of the ancients they give you all the characters but uh you can spend money on silly hats and stuff like that um they actually they added some things recently which are pretty cool in defense of the ancients like you can spend money to um to like make a bet on who will win the game and based on the results of the bet you get items and so it's it's basically the same
你可以，这就是，所以在这个游戏中，据我所知，你唯一花钱的地方是他们有一个角色轮换，只有一部分角色在任何给定时间可以免费使用，所以如果你想确保你最喜欢的角色总是可用，你必须用游戏内货币或你将美元兑换成的游戏内货币购买它，但目前他们没有任何其他花钱的方式，据我所知，是的，我想那是对的，所以是的，嗯，《Dota》(Defense of the Ancients) 他们给你所有的角色，但你可以花钱买愚蠢的帽子之类的东西，他们最近添加了一些东西，在《Dota》中非常酷，比如你可以花钱去赌谁会赢，根据赌注的结果你得到物品，所以这基本上是一样的。
thing like you're you're getting silly hats but because it's like they basically you pay for this gambling mini game that you play while you're playing dota kind of like like you can bet against your own team and stuff like that so uh so those things are actually wait that sounds awful because if you bet against your own team you can just you can just make your team lose uh that's true yeah i never really thought about that but uh this is like why gambling is so controversial amongst people who are professional athletes. But I think the consequence of winning or losing the bet is low enough that it's like, I'm not going to spend an hour playing a game that I've thrown so that I could get, you know,
事情，就像你得到愚蠢的帽子，但因为这基本上是你为这个赌博小游戏付费，你在玩《Dota》时玩这个，比如你可以押注自己的队伍输之类的，所以这些事情实际上是，等等，这听起来很糟糕，因为如果你押注自己的队伍输，你就可以让你的队伍输，那是真的，是的，我从来没想过这一点，但这就像为什么赌博在职业运动员中如此有争议。但我认为赢或输赌注的后果足够小，以至于我不会花一个小时玩一个我故意输掉的游戏，只是为了得到，你知道，
one one hundredth of a silly hat. So anyways, they have a bunch of cool things like that. So I'm sure Vainglory will go in the same direction eventually all right all right so on to rust on um yeah rust is rust is pretty cool i uh actually this was a user request i believe um somebody's i think multiple user requests yeah that's true multiple so uh i didn't even know about rust um and uh you know it hasn't hasn't really made hacker news or at least i haven't seen it on hacker news uh actually i take it back you must not look at it very often yeah i was gonna say i'm sure it's made hacker news but i just happen to not catch it um but uh it's just
百分之一顶愚蠢的帽子。所以无论如何，他们有很多类似这样很酷的东西。所以我相信《虚荣》最终也会朝着同样的方向发展。好了，好了，接下来是 Rust。嗯，是的，Rust 很酷，我其实，我相信这是一个用户请求，我想是多个用户请求，是的，那是真的，多个，所以我甚至不知道 Rust，而且你知道它并没有真正登上 Hacker News，或者至少我没在 Hacker News 上看到它，其实我收回前言，你一定不常看它，是的，我本来想说，我肯定它上过 Hacker News，只是我碰巧没看到，但它只是
it's the same as this new trend of languages to have the same name as common things. Go, Rust. Uh, I don't know of another good example, but it's this problem. Like you see it and it's not clear that it's this. Also, there was a video game called Rust or is a video game called Rust. So for a long time, I thought they were talking about the video game. Yeah.
和这种语言命名为常见事物的趋势一样。Go，Rust。嗯，我不知道另一个好的例子，但这就是这个问题。就像你看到它，但不清楚它指的是这个。此外，还有一个叫 Rust 的电子游戏，或者说有一个叫 Rust 的电子游戏。所以很长一段时间，我以为他们在谈论那个电子游戏。是的。
Yeah. Why do they do that? They should make it something very clear. X, Y, Z, Z, Y or something. No, do not call it that that do not name a language that um do you know what that's from oh x y z z y is the is the code you had to put in adventure to open this door and uh there was some way to figure out it was that, but it was super hard. Anyways, so Rust. Okay, so Rust, it's like C++. It tries to be close to the metal.
是的。他们为什么要那样做？他们应该让它非常清晰。X, Y, Z, Z, Y 之类的。不，不要那样叫它，不要给语言起那个名字，嗯，你知道那来自哪里吗？哦，X Y Z Z Y 是你在《冒险》(Adventure) 中打开那扇门必须输入的代码，而且有一种方法可以弄清楚是那个，但它非常难。无论如何，所以 Rust。好的，所以 Rust，它就像 C++。它试图接近底层。
It's meant for system software, web servers, socket servers, those kind of things, embedded. It compiles straight to machine code, so it could be used for embedded. It uses LLVM. those kind of things, you know, embedded. It compiles straight to machine code, so it could be used for embedded. It uses LLVM. So if you have like an LLVM to machine code compiler for your, you know, Raspberry, Raspberry Pi is a bad example, but for your crazy architecture, Motorola, whatever, then it can, it'll work.
它旨在用于系统软件、Web 服务器、套接字服务器、这类东西，嵌入式。它直接编译成机器码，所以它可以用于嵌入式。它使用 LLVM。这类东西，你知道，嵌入式。它直接编译成机器码，所以它可以用于嵌入式。它使用 LLVM。所以如果你有一个针对你的，你知道，树莓派（树莓派是一个糟糕的例子），但针对你的疯狂架构，摩托罗拉，无论什么，的 LLVM 到机器码编译器，那么它就能工作。
You don't have to, you don't need any, an Intel processor or anything like that. It tries to be very memory safe. So what that means is you actually can't get a null pointer exception at runtime. So the way the language is designed, if it's possible for you to null pointer exception, the compiler will just not allow that code to be compiled, which is pretty cool because most null pointer exceptions,
你不需要任何 Intel 处理器或类似的东西。它试图做到非常内存安全。这意味着你在运行时实际上不会得到空指针异常。所以按照语言的设计，如果可能出现空指针异常，编译器就不会允许该代码被编译，这非常酷，因为大多数空指针异常，
it's not because someone is doing something absolutely crazy and there's a chance of it happening. Most of it are just blind user error. And so if someone is doing that, it's just a bug that they need to fix. Very rarely do you have to do something really wacky with pointers um but with that in mind rust does not allow unsafe pointers so you know for example if you have some fpga that's running on a certain memory address um and you just know that that address you know is 0x12345678 um you can't just say pointer is equal to that um it won't let you do that so um
并不是因为有人在做极其疯狂的事情，而且有发生的可能。大多数只是盲目的用户错误。所以如果有人在做那个，那只是他们需要修复的一个 bug。你很少需要用指针做一些非常古怪的事情，但考虑到这一点，Rust 不允许不安全的指针，所以你知道，例如，如果你有一些在特定内存地址上运行的 FPGA，而且你只是知道那个地址是 0x12345678，你不能直接说指针等于那个，它不会让你那样做，所以
all the pointers have to kind of come from references to objects and wait so how do you how do you do that then i don't think you can do it i mean i'm assuming they'll add like an unsafe pointer you know some way to do that but at the moment you can't do it um so uh yeah so same thing with like in place uh new and things like that placement new you can't really do that yet um but in exchange you get a bunch of cool stuff you get type inferencing you get you know complete memory safety um a bunch of cool features one thing they have um a common problem is if you have multi-threading and you share a pointer to an object with another thread then it's very difficult to to keep track of who owns this object.
所有的指针都必须来自对对象的引用，等等，那你怎么做呢？我不认为你能做到，我的意思是，我假设他们会添加像不安全指针之类的东西，你知道某种方法来做到这一点，但目前你做不到，所以是的，同样的事情，比如原地 new 之类的，placement new 你还不能真正做到，但作为交换，你得到了一堆很酷的东西，你得到类型推断，你得到完整的内存安全，一堆很酷的特性。他们有一个共同的问题是，如果你有多线程，并且你与另一个线程共享一个对象的指针，那么很难跟踪谁拥有这个对象。
It's always kind of a nightmare. So what Rust does is it says the thread that created... So the way that Rust works is you create a box, and a box is basically a wrapper around a pointer, which says that I want this pointer to go to another thread, this data. And you can share boxes with other threads, but at the end of the day, you have to own the memory. So if another thread tries to delete a box that it didn't create, the compiler gets unhappy.
这总是一种噩梦。所以 Rust 所做的是，它说创建它的线程……所以 Rust 的工作方式是你创建一个 box，而 box 基本上是一个指针的包装器，它说我想要这个指针去另一个线程，这个数据。你可以与其他线程共享 box，但归根结底，你必须拥有内存。所以如果另一个线程试图删除一个它没有创建的 box，编译器就会不高兴。
Yeah, and so which thread created the box is actually encoded sort of in the box type. So there's that. It has traits, which are similar to interfaces in Java. But one difference is you can actually have function bodies in traits, but the functions, there can't be any data members. So in other words, you know, like in Java, if you have an interface, you can't have like int a as a member of the interface.
是的，所以哪个线程创建了 box 实际上以某种方式编码在 box 类型中。所以有那个。它有 traits，类似于 Java 中的接口。但一个区别是，你实际上可以在 traits 中有函数体，但函数不能有任何数据成员。换句话说，你知道，就像在 Java 中，如果你有一个接口，你不能有像 int a 这样的接口成员。
It doesn't let you have data. And that's because of the diamond problem, right? Like if you have two interfaces with an int a and you have a class that implements both of them, now it becomes like very a nightmare right it's ambiguous so they don't let you do that but you can have functions the catches the function body you basically your only parameters can be what gets passed into the function which is cool so for example if you, you could have an interface called, like, square and have a function called area.
它不允许你有数据。这是因为菱形问题，对吧？如果你有两个带有 int a 的接口，而你有一个实现这两个接口的类，现在它变得像噩梦一样，它是模棱两可的，所以他们不允许你那样做，但你可以有函数，捕获函数体，你基本上唯一的参数可以是传递给函数的内容，这很酷，所以例如，你可以有一个叫 square 的接口，并有一个叫 area 的函数。
But it would have to take the length of the square as a parameter. But, yeah, there might be cases where you need functions like that. So this is like, yeah, that's the same thing as a function pointer. Yeah, yeah, it's basically a function pointer. So that's pretty cool that was i thought that was very clever um it has two run times which i thought was interesting so it has native and green um in native mode rust behaves just like c or c++ you know if you create a new thread um you know using p threads or win threads or whatever
但它必须把正方形的长度作为参数。但是，是的，可能存在需要这种函数的情况。所以这就像，是的，这和函数指针是一样的。是的，是的，它基本上是一个函数指针。所以这很酷，我觉得这非常聪明，它有两个运行时，我觉得这很有趣，所以它有 native 和 green，在 native 模式下，Rust 的行为就像 C 或 C++，你知道，如果你创建一个新线程，你知道使用 pthreads 或 winthreads 或其他什么，
in c++ then uh it's it's a new thread. And so the OS keeps track of all the threads and all of that. As you remember from our Go podcast, we talked all about coroutines and Rust supports coroutines. So if you use the green Rust runtime, then you get support for coroutines, which is pretty cool. So, you know, there might be cases where you have very limited memory or you need real-time guarantees and things like that. You can use the native Rust runtime for that. And for everyone else, we can use the green Rust runtime,
在 C++ 中，那么它就是一个新线程。所以操作系统会跟踪所有的线程等等。正如你从我们的 Go 播客中记得的那样，我们谈论了所有关于协程的内容，而 Rust 支持协程。所以如果你使用 green Rust 运行时，那么你就得到了对协程的支持，这非常酷。所以，你知道，可能存在内存非常有限或者你需要实时保证之类的情况。你可以为此使用 native Rust 运行时。而对于其他人，我们可以使用 green Rust 运行时，
and now it behaves like Go. But you have to choose one per program? You have to choose... That's right. Per binary? That's right. It's actually, I think, a different compiler or something like that. Oh, okay. Yeah. Is the API similar enough that you can move it back and forth? Actually, it's identical. So for both of them, there's an idea in Rust called a task,
现在它的行为就像 Go。但你必须每个程序选择一个？你必须选择……没错。每个二进制文件？没错。实际上，我想，是一个不同的编译器之类的。哦，好的。是的。API 是否足够相似，以至于你可以来回切换？实际上，它是相同的。所以对于两者，Rust 中有一个叫 task 的概念，
which is basically like a thread. They're all kind of the same thing. So in Rust, you create tasks. And if you're using the native Rust runtime, a task becomes a thread you use the green runtime a task is a coroutine but none of your code changes so it just the guarantees change like if um you actually specify the size of the thread pool so let's say just keep things simple let's say you have a thread pool of size two so you have that means that you have you know one thread available for your main uh thread then there's one other thread so if you spawn two tasks in rust and you have a green runtime with a thread pool size of two
这基本上就像一个线程。它们都是同一种东西。所以在 Rust 中，你创建 tasks。如果你使用 native Rust 运行时，task 变成一个线程，你使用 green 运行时，task 是一个协程，但你的代码没有任何改变，所以只是保证改变了，比如，如果你实际上指定了线程池的大小，所以让我们简单点，假设你有一个大小为 2 的线程池，这意味着你有一个可用于主线程的线程，然后还有另一个线程，所以如果你在 Rust 中生成两个任务，并且你有一个线程池大小为 2 的 green 运行时，
it can't execute both of those because it's already using one for the main thread and only has one left. So it'll execute those two spawned tasks serially. So if you use the native version of the runtime, then every time you call spawn, you're going to get a new operating system thread and it's going to start. So it's a guarantee that if I call spawn, this code is going to start executing as fast as possible, right? Well, it's gonna let your OS try to decide. Yeah, that's right. I mean, yeah, the guarantee is that is that you will be it will do the best the language can. That's right. That's right. So, but with the coroutine, you know, if you have a thread pool size of two and you execute, you know, 10,000 coroutines,
它不能同时执行这两个任务，因为它已经用了一个给主线程，只剩下一个了。所以它会串行执行那两个生成的任务。所以如果你使用 native 版本的运行时，那么每次你调用 spawn，你都会得到一个新的操作系统线程，它就会开始。所以这是一个保证，如果我调用 spawn，这段代码会尽可能快地开始执行，对吧？嗯，它会让你的操作系统来决定。是的，没错。我的意思是，是的，保证是它会尽语言所能做到最好。是的，没错。所以，但对于协程，你知道，如果你有一个大小为 2 的线程池，并且你执行了 10,000 个协程，
they're all going to execute sequentially. Whereas if you have 10,000 threads, they're all going to execute in parallel. I mean, that might, yeah, that might hurt you. Yeah. So in practice, you know, 10,000 threads, probably not a good idea. But, you know, 10,000 threads, probably not a good idea. But, you know, in theory, that's how the native one works.
它们都会顺序执行。而如果你有 10,000 个线程，它们都会并行执行。我的意思是，那可能会，是的，那可能会伤害你。是的。所以在实践中，你知道，10,000 个线程，可能不是个好主意。但是，你知道，理论上，native 版本就是这样工作的。
So I would imagine the native mode is only for people doing, like, very low-level embedded where they really need that, you know. Yeah, that's interesting. I've not really heard of something that like out of the box wanted to support two runtimes other things do support multiple runtimes but well this actually came from go so i so one of the common criticisms of go is that you can't guarantee that a go routine is going to start even you know within minutes of when you create it. And so I guess that's a pain point for some people. So, you know, I personally, not a big fan. I feel like if you need something to start, you know, within a minute,
所以我认为 native 模式只适用于那些做非常底层嵌入式的人，他们真的需要那个，你知道。是的，这很有趣。我还没听说过有什么东西开箱即用就想支持两个运行时，其他东西确实支持多个运行时，但嗯，这实际上来自 Go，所以我认为 Go 的一个常见批评是你不能保证一个 goroutine 会开始，甚至在你创建它后的几分钟内。所以我猜这对某些人来说是一个痛点。所以，你知道，我个人，不是粉丝。我觉得如果你需要什么东西开始，你知道，在一分钟内，
then you're probably doing something wrong. But, you know, who knows? Yeah, I don't know sometimes these pain points, if people actually ran across a legitimate problem or they're just imagining in theory this could become a problem. But in practice, you wouldn't actually hit it. Yeah, exactly. I'm thinking in practice, either one of two things.
那么你可能做错了什么。但是，你知道，谁知道呢？是的，我不知道，有时这些痛点，如果人们真的遇到了合法的问题，或者他们只是在理论上想象这可能成为一个问题。但在实践中，你不会真的遇到它。是的，完全正确。我在想在实践中，要么是两件事之一。
Either you're doing like a web server where, you know, if you have a few seconds in between like when you spawn a task and when it executes, it's not that big a deal. Or you're doing some very low level embedded, in which case you don't have that many tasks. So they would just start right away anyways. So, yeah, if you're not if you're doing embedded, you're not running any of these languages. Let's just be honest. That's true. But you could be.
要么你在做像 Web 服务器这样的东西，你知道，如果你在生成任务和它执行之间有几秒钟，那没什么大不了的。或者你在做一些非常底层的嵌入式，在这种情况下你没有那么多任务。所以它们无论如何都会立即开始。所以，是的，如果你在做嵌入式，你不会运行任何这些语言。让我们诚实一点。那是真的。但你可能是。
There's no reason why you could maybe it'd be nice there's really no reason why you couldn't run rust on even a motorola i've not looked enough at its compiler but yeah well it goes through llvm which is what clang goes through they make the claim that their whole goal of the language is to be as fast as clang or be as close to clang performance wise as possible while still having you know these features and they claim to be pretty close so who knows okay um so yeah it was made by a motor mozilla employee so actually i wanted to talk about this for a little bit so have you heard of m scripted yes so m scripted we've talked about it i believe yes in our javascript episode yeah yeah so m scripted was created by mozilla employee and this was and basically i feel like mozilla employees are just very creative people
没有理由你不能，也许会很好，真的没有理由你不能在摩托罗拉上运行 Rust，我没有足够地研究它的编译器，但是的，嗯，它通过 LLVM，也就是 Clang 所经过的，他们声称他们语言的全部目标是尽可能快地达到 Clang 的速度，或者在性能上尽可能接近 Clang，同时仍然拥有这些特性，他们声称非常接近，所以谁知道呢。好的，嗯，所以是的，它是由一个 Mozilla 员工制作的，所以我其实想谈谈这个，所以你听说过 Emscripten 吗？是的，Emscripten 我们谈论过它，我相信是的，在我们的 JavaScript 剧集中，是的，是的，所以 Emscripten 是由 Mozilla 员工创建的，这基本上我觉得 Mozilla 员工是非常有创造力的人，
like it just seems like or at least these two were well yeah maybe it just i i get the impression that like a lot of the cool stuff that's coming out now is coming out from mozilla employees but i could be wrong i don't know i i guess for the size of the company it just seems like they're creating a lot of cool stuff but i mean they're also their wheelhouse is also very well aligned with what the internet would think is cool, right? So, you know, Mozilla is concentrated mostly on making browser and web-related tools and products. I don't know if they do anything else. But, like, I don't even think they're doing server stuff or whatever.
就像，或者至少这两个是，嗯，是的，也许只是，我得到一个印象，现在很多很酷的东西都是来自 Mozilla 员工，但我可能是错的，我不知道，我猜对于公司规模来说，他们似乎创造了很多很酷的东西，但我的意思是，他们的专长也非常符合互联网认为很酷的东西，对吧？所以，你知道，Mozilla 主要集中在制作浏览器和 Web 相关的工具和产品。我不知道他们是否做其他任何事情。但是，就像，我甚至不认为他们在做服务器端的东西之类的。
But maybe, maybe. Yeah. And so, but that's what people would find cool. Because if you're a web programmer, right, you're going to be very interested in something like Emscripten or Rust. You know, not so much. It doesn't seem as exactly in their wheelhouse, but. Yeah, that's a fair point.
但也许，也许。是的。所以，但这正是人们会觉得酷的东西。因为如果你是一个 Web 程序员，对吧，你会对像 Emscripten 或 Rust 这样的东西非常感兴趣。你知道，没那么多。它看起来并不完全在他们的专长范围内，但是。是的，这是一个公平的观点。
Yeah. I guess I can explain how it would be work related and how, what you're working on there would be of interest to like, it's a very popular thing right now. Right. Yeah. Right. Um, yeah, it's still, but that's a good point there's a lot of good stuff seeming to come out of mozilla i can't dispute that yeah oh the other thing is they
是的。我猜我可以解释它将如何与工作相关，以及你在那里工作的内容将如何引起兴趣，比如，它现在是一个非常流行的东西。对。是的。对。嗯，是的，它仍然是，但这是一个好观点，似乎有很多好东西来自 Mozilla，我不能反驳这一点。是的，哦，另一件事是他们
created like an all javascript pdf renderer which i thought was pretty cool i don't know it's just kind of goofy stuff nothing nothing like groundbreaking but just kind of cool like this is what i would do if i had a bunch of free time um anyways well you should go work at mozilla then apparently yeah apparently mozilla gives you a lot of freedom um so i have a it says your great standard library so uh this is the batteries included thing yep so a lot of tools out of the box that you get to do common operations so you're not gonna have to go write your own json encoder or decoder yeah i mean that's one thing about c++ that kills me like there's no easy way to go from c++ objects to disk and back without having to write a bunch of boilerplate like the
创建了一个全 JavaScript 的 PDF 渲染器，我觉得这很酷，我不知道，这只是有点傻的东西，没什么开创性的，但只是有点酷，就像如果我有大量空闲时间我会做的事情，无论如何，嗯，那你应该去 Mozilla 工作，显然，是的，显然 Mozilla 给了你很多自由，所以我有一个，它说你的很棒的标准库，所以嗯，这是电池包含的东西，是的，开箱即用有很多工具可以做常见的操作，所以你不需要去写你自己的 JSON 编码器或解码器，是的，我的意思是这是 C++ 的一件事，让我很痛苦，就像没有简单的方法可以将 C++ 对象存入磁盘并取回，而不必写一堆样板代码，就像
best is the boost serialization library and even that one's not that great i mean ultimately c++ doesn't have reflection so you know it just there's no way to do it but this does so uh actually this this doesn't have reflection but the language it's like the compiler itself has this auto serialization built in that's how they get that's how they pull it off um so yeah on the cons we talked about this already but you know obviously going to be slower than c++ um they make the claim you know if you tried to write all of these memory safety checks and stuff yourself in c++ that they would be faster but that's not saying much because uh that's not what people want to know people want to know is like what kind of performance hit am i going to take you know um the other con is too early yeah that's not what people want to know. What people want to know is like, what kind of performance hit am I going to take?
最好的是 Boost 序列化库，即使那个也不是很好，我的意思是最终 C++ 没有反射，所以你知道，没有办法做到这一点，但这个有，所以嗯，其实这个没有反射，但语言，就像编译器本身有这种内置的自动序列化，这就是他们实现它的方式，所以是的，关于缺点，我们已经谈过了，但你知道显然会比 C++ 慢，他们声称你知道，如果你尝试自己写所有这些内存安全检查之类的东西，它们会更快，但这说明不了什么，因为这不是人们想知道的，人们想知道的是，我将承受什么样的性能打击，你知道，另一个缺点是太早了，是的，那不是人们想知道的。人们想知道的是，我将承受什么样的性能打击？
The other con is too early. Yeah, that's always the problem, right? Is like in C++ for right or wrong, you don't do that. But there are certain areas where you kind of say like, I want to sacrifice, I get in trouble for this. I do a lot of low level programming and I get in trouble all the time. People are like, oh, this is not considered the safe way
另一个缺点是太早了。是的，那总是问题，对吧？就像在 C++ 中，无论对错，你都不会那样做。但有些领域你有点说，我想牺牲，我为此惹上麻烦。我做了很多底层编程，我一直惹上麻烦。人们说，哦，这在 C 中不被认为是安全的方法
to do this in C. And it's like, oh, this is not considered the safe way to do this in C. And it's like, well, this is some graphics routine that needs to run X number of times a second a lot and needs to run really, really, really fast. So yes, you may think that it's not harmful to add, not make this an inline function, like just make it a normal function. But it's like I measured it and turns out on our platform that it's 10% i measured it and turns out on our platform that
来做这个。就像，哦，这在 C 中不被认为是安全的方法来做这个。就像，嗯，这是一个图形例程，需要每秒运行 X 次，而且需要运行得非常非常非常快。所以是的，你可能认为添加这个，不把它做成内联函数，就像把它做成一个普通函数，并没有害处。但就像我测量过它，结果在我们的平台上，它是 10% 我测量过它，结果在我们的平台上
it's you know 10 faster to make this inline at the expense of a little bit of code size even though that's a violation of like the standard it's like but i measured it on our platform and in this circumstance i need the speed over the the you know share it's not premature optimization well maybe it is but i don't think it's premature you know we got to the point we needed the speed and now it's time to do it. And you can. Yeah. Versus like something like, you know, when you hear tools or whatever saying, oh, well, if you try to do all this in another language, you know, it wouldn't be as fast.
它是你知道 10% 更快，通过牺牲一点代码大小来内联它，即使这违反了标准，就像但我测量过它在我们的平台上，在这种情况下，我需要速度超过你知道共享，这不是过早优化，嗯，也许是，但我不认为它是过早的，你知道，我们达到了我们需要速度的地步，现在是时候做它了。而且你可以。是的。相比像，你知道，当你听到工具或其他什么说，哦，好吧，如果你尝试在另一种语言中做所有这些，你知道，它不会那么快。
It's like, well, but sometimes I don't want to do all that. Yeah, exactly. I mean, if you use Rust, you're handcuffed to doing all that stuff, whether you want it or not um but for 99 point some number of nines you probably don't actually need to you shouldn't be skipping those things anyways yeah um my biggest con with rust is that uh it doesn't have good third-party library support and specifically it doesn't have any way to communicate with other like programs written in other languages you know like protocol buffers thrift avro like even just having one of these would make a huge difference so no good rpc support yeah
就像，好吧，但有时我不想做所有这些。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果你使用 Rust，你被束缚着去做所有那些事情，无论你想要还是不想要，但对于 99 点一些数字的 9，你可能实际上不需要，无论如何你不应该跳过那些东西，是的，嗯，我对 Rust 最大的缺点是它没有好的第三方库支持，特别是它没有任何方法与用其他语言编写的其他程序通信，你知道，像 Protocol Buffers、Thrift、Avro，甚至只要有其中一个就会产生巨大的差异，所以没有好的 RPC 支持，是的。
there's no rpc support um and so yeah i mean there's you know basically it's you know you have to write if you wanted to write part of your application in Rust, you'd have to talk to it through JSON, you know, and you'd have to handle all the deserialization yourself and all that. And so, you know, I'm sure someone will make it. It's just not there yet. And, you know, on top of that, it's it's still an alpha mode. And the developers encourage you to download like the latest bleeding edge build they basically say don't download the stable build because it's missing so many features and we fix so many critical bugs that you're better off getting
没有 RPC 支持，所以是的，我的意思是，你知道，基本上它是，你知道，你必须写，如果你想用 Rust 编写你的部分应用程序，你必须通过 JSON 与它对话，你知道，你必须自己处理所有的反序列化等等。所以，你知道，我相信有人会做出来的。它只是还没到那里。而且，你知道，最重要的是，它仍然处于 alpha 模式。开发人员鼓励你下载像最新的前沿构建，他们基本上说不要下载稳定版本，因为它缺少太多特性，而且我们修复了太多关键 bug，你最好得到
you know today's development branch than the stable release from three months ago and that's don't use this for your work project, but for your hobby project, have at it. Exactly. I mean, it's basically where Go was when we talked about Go. And now Go is much more mature. So I'm sure this will shape up just fine.
今天的开发分支，而不是三个月前的稳定版本，而且那是不要在你的工作项目中使用它，但对于你的爱好项目，尽管去用吧。完全正确。我的意思是，它基本上就是我们谈论 Go 时 Go 所处的位置。现在 Go 成熟多了。所以我相信这会好起来的。
But in the meantime, it's a cool language to learn so that you're ready for when it becomes more widely accepted. Wait, is that the equivalent of playing the stock market? If you guess at what language you think will be big next and you invest a lot of time and effort into trying to learn it so that when it becomes big,
但与此同时，它是一门很酷的语言，可以学习，这样当你准备好它变得更广泛接受时。等等，这相当于玩股票市场吗？如果你猜测你认为哪种语言会成为下一个大语言，并且你投入大量时间和精力去学习它，以便当它变大时，
you'll be one of the first people to be ready for it? Is it like a speculative learning thing? Yeah, I mean, in some way, we were speculators by learning the gpu we just never cashed in on it yeah we didn't get our mad monies story of my life but yeah i remember when tesla ipo'd and i was gonna buy some and oh now it's i had a friend who was telling me like buy tesla buy tesla buy tesla when it was like 40 a share and uh yeah that guy's like rich now he's like a multi-millionaire that hurts you know even like our first show was on bitcoin and if if any of the people no bitcoin has slid a lot now though yeah that's true that's true
你将是第一批准备好的人之一？这是一种投机学习的东西吗？是的，我的意思是，在某种程度上，我们通过学习 GPU 是投机者，我们只是从未从中兑现，是的，我们没有得到我们的疯狂金钱，我生活的故事，但是的，我记得当特斯拉 IPO 时，我打算买一些，哦，现在它是，我有一个朋友告诉我，买特斯拉，买特斯拉，买特斯拉，当它只有 40 美元一股时，而且是的，那个家伙现在很有钱，他像是一个千万富翁，这很伤人，你知道，甚至我们的第一个节目是关于比特币的，如果如果任何人们，不，比特币现在已经下滑了很多，是的，那是真的，那是真的。
so i think it's down i'd have to look at it i i want to say it was down like 50 this year um and so that's always the problem right like your your friend who's a multi-millionaire if he cashed out all his tesla right now but most likely he'll hold on to it and then it'll go down and then like and i shouldn't say most likely all these people invested in bitcoin said oh i'm so rich like my bitcoin's up tenfold 10x right like and then so it's still up 5x but they'll all feel bad because they lost half of what it was worth yeah so then they'll wait for it to go back up as it continues to slide down to zero or goes back up i don't know what bitcoin will do yeah yeah i don't know it's true that is true like uh you whenever you reflect on these things you always reflect on the high. It's almost impossible to time that.
所以我认为它下降了，我得看看它，我想说它今年下降了 50%，所以这总是问题，对吧？就像你的千万富翁朋友，如果他现在兑现了他所有的特斯拉，但很可能他会坚持持有它，然后它会下降，然后就像，我不应该说很可能，所有这些投资比特币的人说，哦，我太有钱了，我的比特币涨了十倍，10 倍，对吧？然后所以它仍然涨了 5 倍，但他们都会感到难过，因为他们损失了它价值的一半，是的，所以他们会等待它回升，因为它继续下滑到零，或者回升，我不知道比特币会做什么，是的，是的，我不知道，这是真的，那是真的，就像，当你反思这些事情时，你总是反思高点。几乎不可能把握那个时机。
I think that... Learn a language before it becomes a real thing. If Rust was a stock, I would invest in Rust. It comes rather close to Go. The Go language. It's unclear why would you use Rust if you use go I mean rust
我认为……在它成为真正的东西之前学习一门语言。如果 Rust 是一只股票，我会投资 Rust。它相当接近 Go。Go 语言。不清楚如果你使用 Go，为什么要使用 Rust，我的意思是 Rust
does have the memory checking I guess that is a big thing that go doesn't have but yeah I guess that would be the that would be the the number one reason to stick with rust but but yeah it's pretty cool check it out you can actually do some pretty fun stuff like get a pointer to a vector and then do pushback and then try to access that pointer. Rust gets unhappy. It says, hey, you did pushback on the vector. You have a vector called Realloc.
确实有内存检查，我猜那是一个 Go 没有的大东西，但是的，我猜那将是坚持使用 Rust 的第一大原因，但是的，它很酷，去看看吧，你实际上可以做一些非常有趣的事情，比如获取一个指向向量的指针，然后做 pushback，然后尝试访问那个指针。Rust 会不高兴。它说，嘿，你对向量做了 pushback。你有一个叫 Realloc 的向量。
Now you're trying to access this pointer again. It feels cool to see the compiler experience something that you would over the course of hours as you tried to debug like that whole process was kind of cool for me so check it out you know compile a few programs it's pretty cool and then uh uh you know wait a couple years until it's until it's awesome so it looks like the high of bitcoin was 950 and it's currently trading at 310 what was it when we made our first episode? That was like five years ago.
现在你又在尝试访问这个指针。看到编译器体验你在数小时内尝试调试时会经历的事情，感觉很酷，就像整个过程对我来说很酷，所以去看看吧，你知道，编译几个程序，它很酷，然后嗯，你知道，等几年，直到它很棒。所以看起来比特币的高点是 950，目前交易价格为 310，当我们制作第一集时它是多少？那是大约五年前。
Hang on. The chart doesn't go back that far. In 2011, it was worth 40 cents. Yeah, there you go. So if you listened to our first episode and bought $1,000 worth of Bitcoin, you're like a millionaire now or something. Wait, if you bought... Oh, I don i don't even know yeah that'd be ridiculous think of that like a thousand
等等。图表没有回溯那么远。在 2011 年，它价值 40 美分。是的，就是这样。所以如果你听了我们的第一集并买了价值 1,000 美元的比特币，你现在就像个百万富翁之类的。等等，如果你买了……哦，我甚至不知道，是的，那太荒谬了，想想那个，像一千
dollars is you know for most people like what two paychecks or something and uh it's just like weird to think about that but again there's no way to know that that would have happened. I'm trying to calculate in my head. The orders of magnitude is throwing me off. So, okay, let's say it was $1 and it went up to $900. That's two orders two times. So if you spent $1,000, you would have made $100,000. So, yeah. So if you invested like, yeah, $1,000, you'd have been like a millionaire.
美元是，你知道，对大多数人来说，像两份工资之类的，而且，想到这一点很奇怪，但同样，没有办法知道那会发生。我正在脑子里计算。数量级让我感到困惑。所以，好的，假设它是 1 美元，它涨到了 900 美元。那是两个数量级，两次。所以如果你花了 1,000 美元，你就会赚到 100,000 美元。所以，是的。所以如果你投资了，是的，1,000 美元，你就会像个百万富翁。
Yeah, isn't that wild? And then if you had done it in like Dogecoin, you'd have been like a millionaire. Yeah, isn't that wild? And then if you had done it in like Dogecoin, you'd have like nothing. Yeah, that's the other thing too, is like your brain is trained to see the outliers. It's not thinking about the millions of other like crazy things that came out that were not popular. It's a legitimate thing, right?
是的，那不是很疯狂吗？然后如果你在像狗狗币上做了，你就会像个百万富翁。是的，那不是很疯狂吗？然后如果你在像狗狗币上做了，你就会像什么都没有。是的，那是另一件事，就像你的大脑被训练去看到异常值。它没有想到数百万其他像疯狂的东西出来，但并不流行。这是一个合法的事情，对吧？
Like, what is it? It's a legitimate thing, right? Like stick, what is it? It's like survivor bias. So if you look at the S and P 500 today and say, if I had bought all those stocks, you know, 10 years ago or whatever, and you say like how much money I made, it's actually not fair because a bunch of stocks,
就像，它是什么？这是一个合法的事情，对吧？就像坚持，它是什么？这就像幸存者偏差。所以如果你看看今天的标准普尔 500 指数，并说，如果我在 10 年前买了所有那些股票，你知道，或者其他什么，你说我赚了多少钱，这实际上是不公平的，因为一堆股票，
which used to be in the S and P 500 10 years ago are now bankrupt and worth nothing. So like you would, it's like survivor bias. You can't take a stock that exists today and trace it back 10 years because you have to look at the number of stocks available 10 years ago. You know what I mean?
过去在 10 年前的标准普尔 500 指数中，现在破产了，一文不值。所以就像你，这就像幸存者偏差。你不能拿一只今天存在的股票并追溯 10 年，因为你必须看看 10 年前可用的股票数量。你知道我的意思吗？
Like when you pull from the distribution 10 years ago of stocks that were on the market 10 years ago, it's different than pulling from today stocks, which also existed 10 years ago because that guarantees they are good companies that survived at market 10 years ago is different than pulling from today stocks, which also existed 10 years ago, because that guarantees they are good companies that survived at least 10 years. Yep, that's right. You know, one thing that amazes me is Silicon Valley still,
就像当你从 10 年前市场上存在的股票分布中提取时，它与从今天的股票中提取不同，今天的股票也存在于 10 年前，因为这保证了它们是好公司，在 10 年前市场上幸存下来，与从今天的股票中提取不同，今天的股票也存在于 10 年前，因为这保证了它们是好公司，至少幸存了 10 年。是的，没错。你知道，有一件事让我感到惊讶，硅谷仍然，
like many parts of Silicon Valley still haven't recovered from the dot-com boom. Like I was looking at specifically housing prices and there's many places like around san jose morgan hill like all these places where housing prices are down like 20 30 percent from their 1999 price like that just blows my freaking mind um but uh yeah the dot-com boom was like a very popular boom right like a lot of people were in on it yeah i mean your stories i remember hearing stories this we were well i don't know about you but i was in high school you're probably in high school right at the time no i don't think i was
硅谷的许多部分仍然没有从互联网泡沫中恢复过来。就像我特别看房价，有很多地方像圣何塞、摩根希尔周围，所有这些地方，房价从 1999 年的价格下跌了 20% 30%，这简直让我震惊，但嗯，是的，互联网泡沫是一个非常流行的繁荣，对吧？就像很多人参与其中，是的，我的意思是你的故事，我记得听到故事，这我们，嗯，我不知道你，但我当时在高中，你当时可能在高中，对吧？不，我不认为我
even in high school yeah but the uh i mean i was hearing stories about like you know yeah like you get a you know you get a brand new car as a sign-on bonus and stuff like that just like ridiculous stories like a like a like a nice car you like a lexus as a sign-on bonus but uh those days are gone and that was someone who just like sat and did excel all day long yeah that's right they wrote a they wrote a ip tracer and visual basic or whatever did you see that csi episode no it's a csi episode it's kind of internet famous where this guy's like uh a hacker is hacking into our csi database we have to stop him and this woman shows up and she goes i'll write a ip tracer and visual basic
甚至在高中，是的，但嗯，我的意思是，我听到关于像，你知道，是的，就像你得到一个，你知道，你得到一辆全新的车作为签约奖金之类的，就像荒谬的故事，就像一辆，就像一辆，像雷克萨斯作为签约奖金，但嗯，那些日子已经过去了，那是某人只是像整天坐着做 Excel，是的，没错，他们写了一个，他们写了一个 IP 追踪器，用 Visual Basic 或其他什么，你看了那集 CSI 吗？不，那是一集 CSI，它在互联网上很有名，这个家伙就像，嗯，一个黑客正在入侵我们的 CSI 数据库，我们必须阻止他，这个女人出现了，她说我会用 Visual Basic 写一个 IP 追踪器
and he's like good get on it so funny, thank you to all our listeners and current viewers. Yeah. All the dozens of you. Yeah, yeah. I mean, we have a number of people on the Twitch stream. My Twitch, for some reason, is flipping out. So I can't actually tell how many people are on the Twitch stream. But I feel like it's more than there was last time, which is pretty cool.
他说好，开始吧。太搞笑了，感谢我们所有的听众和现在的观众。是的。你们这几十个人。是的，是的。我的意思是，我们在 Twitch 流上有很多人。我的 Twitch，由于某种原因，正在发疯。所以我实际上无法判断 Twitch 流上有多少人。但我觉得比上次多，这很酷。
We're the new Bitcoin, baby. Yeah, that's right. We're the Bitcoin of podcasts. The activity on Google+, on Facebook has been great. Lots of user questions. This time
我们是新的比特币，宝贝。是的，没错。我们是播客界的比特币。Google+、Facebook 上的活动一直很棒。很多用户问题。这次
we did something a little different where we just picked a few of the top user feedback and read it out. I felt like it went pretty well. It's a lot of interesting content. So thanks for that. Um, thanks for listening and checking out your books and tools, the show and all of that. And, uh, and there actually are way more than dozens of listeners and we appreciate all of you. That's right. We have, we have dozens of viewers, but thousands of listeners and a big shout out to you guys for guys for, you know, it's because of you that we make this show. So that's what sort of keeps it fun for us. Well, see you in the 2015.
我们做了一些不同的尝试，挑选了一些热门的用户反馈并读了出来。我觉得效果还不错，内容非常有趣。感谢大家的反馈。嗯，感谢大家的收听，也感谢大家关注我们的书籍、工具、节目以及所有相关内容。其实我们的听众远不止几十位，我们非常感谢每一位听众。没错，我们有几十位观众，但有数千位听众，特别感谢你们，正是因为有你们，我们才制作这档节目。这也是让我们乐在其中的原因。那么，2015年再见。
That's right. Have a happy new year, happy holidays and all of that. And I will see you next year. The intro music is Axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没错。祝大家新年快乐，节日快乐。我们明年见。片头音乐是biner pilot的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown节目采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，也可以进行重混或改编，但必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。